hey phil this is uh luke from kansas
city
luke from kc and we appreciate you
brother
and i was uh i was in a
burning building once in kansas city um
but i just made a sandwich and so i
didn't evacuate and i ate that sandwich
homework i'm over here trying not to
delete
one of these uh cigarettes that i got
burned in my pocket right now
uh i just wanted to call and say i love
the show man i
um i really appreciate it make me laugh
man your uh
commentary on tampa which i have a good
friend
and i took into underbelly of tampa
um was spot on oh yeah tampa's a good
place to get a
i mean somebody will take your organs
right out of your body with a knife and
then freaking
you know sell you a cigar bro
gang [ __ ] homework uh my i just had a
question about
you know i have a son he's uh he's
coming of age you know
not too soon he's nine but i know that
you know the time's coming for the birds
and the bees
and i just wanted to get your take on
how do you break that down you know i
know i didn't really get
you know too much uh explaining
you know when i was younger and uh just
want to give them the tools man and i
just want to give you
you know what are your thoughts on uh
you know
the birds and the bees to it to a young
man
amen thank you so much for that question
and he's talking about sex he's talking
about sex he's not talking about pets or
anything like that he's talking about
sex for children
and um you know it's
here's the thing i think the thing is
with talking about sex with children
you want to be the first person to to
to to kind of
to present it to him you want to be the
diving board
he's going to hear something he'll hear
a word
you want to be the one to start the
to present it to him because i remember
when i was young
they had a fella in our neighborhood who
ended up actually
taking his uh grandmother's life
and she was our lunch lady and r.i.p
annie and uh
and she scooped you out the peas and
[ __ ] [ __ ]
by the time she got that scoop to you
she had half the peas on her she had
damn dyslexia in her wrists
you know she couldn't put together a
damn scoop of peas but uh
but anyway um what wasn't talking about
oh this dude so he made i mean he didn't
make it but he this dude one time
you know he masturbated and he j.o
jerked out you know spraying out they
called it locally
but he jerked up and uh he made us kind
of watch him
he didn't make us watch him but this was
right after football season ended
right before baseball so kind of that
time when there wasn't you know not not
a lot going on
and so he you know was opportune time if
you
you know this is you know if it was just
you know tom you'd almost try anything
you know you try you know you know you'd
eat laffy taffys even though you hated
them you'd you know
but anyway this guy jerk dog made us
watch him anyway his dad
saw it happen and his dad was not
pleased with it so i remember his dad
made us
sit in their house and he put like stick
them on our hands
you know like a spray enamel
um and he
then you put our hand like a sand like a
coarse kind of sand
and then he made us look at pornography
in their living room
and so we're there watching and he told
he said you can't touch yourselves you
know so everybody's just sitting there
damn erect
and uh and the dad was making chili the
whole time
he's making chili in the kitchen man so
i can't even drive through cincinnati
without just
springing board you feel me but um
anyway but here's what i'm saying is i
didn't know anything about sex and you
you
you want to be the one to to to to
introduce him to it
you don't want some guy you know spray
enamel in his hands out there and making
him watch pornography
so they got you just uh you know you got
to be you got to be
a part of his life i remember i heard
the word dildo
and somebody at school was like do you
know what a dildo is
i was like yeah and i didn't know
and they didn't tell me and then i'm on
the school bus and i told the school bus
driver
miss hazel i told her straight up she
had them big ass dildos on her chest
and um and she sent me the principal
office
and this one they still spanked you
so lawton makita's man spanked the f out
of me
but nobody still told me what it meant
no i just didn't know anything
you know it was just a different time
man um
my buddy scotty's dad he came one time i
was staying with them
he came in the bedroom he said look
first time at his house he goes you
fellas can sleep
pull the pole or hold a hole
but don't sleep pulled a hole
i don't know what the hell he was
talking about dude we tried to figure it
out we
we're laying there and flipping over and
doing this and that and
hell i know i just slept on the floor i
slept at the foot of the bed next to a
damn um
uh they had a golden retriever but um
anyway you do i'm saying you want to be
the one to talk to him
you want to be the one to prevent
present the information i remember
another one of mine
his this boy jeff and his daddy did mail
and daddy did uh you know post manning
and he one time he he he he said you
want don't want to find a loose woman he
said
and he put like a little bag over my
head from the store
a tight bag and he put it on my head
kind of taped it around my neck a little
bit he said you feel that
i said yeah i could barely breathe you
know and then he took that off and then
he put his mailbag over my head us
postal mail said on u.s
mail and he said you feel that you got
all this room in that [ __ ]
and he said you want the first one
and so that's how he was trying to teach
me about women and loose women
and he said if she'll smoke she'll poke
and i mean if you if a woman was doing a
cigarette they was willing to do sex
you know just old little limericks and
stuff scottish kind of stuff
so anyway i think you just want to be
the person to talk to them
you know you want to be the uh
you want to be the person to talk to
them so maybe just ask me
i think a good way could be is there
words that you haven't heard before
is there are there words you have any
questions about are there terms you've
heard
um you know do you have any thoughts
about your body you have any thoughts
about other people's bodies
you know have him draw a titty see where
he's at with it
you know have him you know ask him what
if he knows anything about a cooter see
what he said
he might not know nothing so
but um anyway but that's a
suggestion i have if you have a
suggestion on how to teach a child about
the birds
and the bees you can hit the hotline
985-664-9503
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah